one of the ways to get really happy is
to start to chip away and not judge in
people because I think it's a complete
and utter indicator to the fact that
you're judging yourself which is the
quickest way to not be happy you're
practicing judging you're a [__]
judge you're [__] Judge Judy stop
stop judging yourself which then allows
you to stop judging others there's a
different question which is like okay so
what's the value of your judgment like
all right great you're [__] judging
that band it's like yelling at the
television from home pass the ball it's
not gonna [__] make them pass the
ball you know like
oh I [__] yelled at every hour that's
all I do